who told me now is Bollywood superstar
and UN environments goodwill ambassador
for India dia mirza a real pleasure
talking to you thank you for joining us
in this afternoon so I see you made a
goodwill ambassador back in 2017 what
does that work in sale I'm sorry I
didn't follow your question that there's
a lot of feedback on the ocean
sure III see you made a goodwill
ambassador back in 2017 so I just had to
get a sense of what that work entails
well it primarily involves advocacy
bringing the science to the people and
you know really bridging the gap between
science and civil society there is so
much science available today that helps
us make better choices as human beings
and for too long that has not been
accessible to civil society and I think
that the that the most important part of
my work is to take that science to the
people what are you most proud of I'm
most proud of the Beach plastic
pollution campaign I think that it's
brought about a huge huge shift more
people today recognize how terrible our
choices of consumption and plastic have
been and how terrifying the production
of plastics has been and especially so
much of the statistics that I think had
had not been accessible to people you
know simple facts like they'll be more
plastic in the oceans than fish by 2050
the fact that every one minute a truck
full of plastic enters our oceans
there's just so much that I think more
people know today than ever before but I
think the the predominant part of the
campaign was the awareness and
understanding that most of this plastic
that is produced annually fifty percent
of it is single-use and as human beings
as
people we can so easily refuse this
plastic and I think it's not about big
change even in a commitment from our
Prime Minister on World Environment Day
saying that India would become
single-use plastics free by 2022 I think
that's big I'm interested in if you've
always been very aware of the dangers to
the environment you know being Indian I
see that none of the world's 10 most
polluted cities in the world are in
India so growing up was it something
that you were very conscious of
absolutely I was growing up in a city
called Hyderabad I was born in 1981
that's actually the year that the
climate report indicated that global
warming was happening and that I mean we
as human beings need to do a lot more to
act upon the fact that we were impacting
the climate negatively through our
choice of consumption and Industry and
my formative years whether in school or
at home drew my attention repeatedly to
how important our personal choices of
consumption were and how they would
impact the environment I think it's in
the last 10 years that I have really
become a strong advocate because I
recognized how so little was being done
to draw our attention to how fully we
were managing our waste and treating our
environment I did a doc you travel show
three years ago where I traveled from
the source of the Ganges all the way to
sea and it was slow travel so I was
driving through road through villages
and towns in cities of five states in
India and all I could see through that
travel was just heaps and heaps and
heaps and ravines of plastic waste and
it got me thinking it really really got
me thinking about the numbers and the
fact that every practically every item
of food and beverage today is packaged
in plastic and we clearly don't have the
infrastructure to support the
management of that waste and it's
landing up in our oceans and our rivers
in our waterways in landfills it's being
incinerated it's it's polluting our soil
our air our water and it it just I think
in so many ways fuel my purpose to do
more and and raise more awareness and
just through actively get involved and
asking questions like what is happening
with extended producers responsibilities
why is it that the world is producing so
much plastic and it has nowhere to go
and it's polluting the environment the
way it is and we're just not doing
enough dear you mentioned infrastructure
the infrastructure there do you get the
sense that the the me the attitude from
people is beginning to change because in
many of these countries in developing
world you know there is object poverty
so for a lot of people their main
priority is really getting food on the
table for themselves and their children
oh absolutely I think a big part of the
problem lies especially in third-world
countries
lies in the fact that we have bigger
problems and we perceive other problems
as bigger problems you know we have
matching malnutrition we have we have we
have a lot of issues and I think that
this until and unless the world
collectively recognizes that the first
and the primary you know impact that we
have on human health and all human
securities comes from the environment we
are not going to change that attitude
you know we can hope for better
education for our children we can hope
for empowering empowerment of women but
until we recognize that the first thing
that secures the right to life is the
health of the environment we're not
going to change I'm interesting get your
thoughts on skies deep ocean life
projects that quest examined the impact
of climate change and the plastic
pollution in our ocean I mean when you
first heard about that project what was
your initial reaction
I was very very excited and and and I
think that this is an extremely
effective way of helping people
understand the magnitude of the issue
I've always used Babar diems phrase
where he says that in the end we will
protect only that what we love and we
will love only that what we learn about
and I think you know the deep ocean
rescue and the sky ocean rescue campaign
is one that will help people understand
the magnitude of the problem but also
just learn to love our oceans that much
more and do you think there is so much
more to learn about our oceans oh
absolutely I think - I mean there's not
enough understanding of how much the
oceans impact and bring balance to our
planet there are millions of lives that
are dependent on oceans but that apart I
think the one thing that definitively
balances our climate is the ocean and
when we disrupt the balance of the ocean
we are you know increasing our risks
every day I'm sure you're well aware the
global walkouts that took place amongst
some schoolchildren protesting tryna get
raise awareness about the issues of the
dangers facing our environment is that
saying that you would welcome something
that you you were supports so absolutely
I'm a big fan of Greta Hamburg I think
my god her voice is so powerful and and
the fact that she's really really
compared the world and children across
the world to come together and
you know initiative in it initiate and
be part of the global movement climate
strike I think it's absolutely fantastic
but I also think that it's children who
are going to use their voice more
effectively now than perhaps ever before
and I'm most certain that governments
and policymakers and industries will be
compelled to listen to these voices
because we do not have a choice we have
to act on climate now yeah and they're
just a final thought for me I mean there
will be people who will be watching this
right now who will say no that they have
to prioritize whether it's you know
going to work putting food on the table
of themselves and their children as I
mentioned earlier on or doing other
things I mean what would you what would
you say to them about the importance of
getting involved in saving the
environments I think every one of us has
the power to make a difference
I think our personal life choices can
contribute significantly towards that
change whether it's the choice we made
it in the food we eat by reducing our
consumption of meat by going vegan or
being mostly vegetarian by refusing the
use of single-use plastics I mean seeing
no to simple things like a plastic bag
or plastic straw and just drawing our
awareness in our everyday consumption
patterns and and then of course if you
want to do more you can support
organizations that conserve and protect
the environment you can Lobby and get
governments to pass that our laws and
improve their jurisdiction there's a lot
of good that each one of us can do but
yes I think I think the change can start
with every individual and we are all
capable of making a big change by just
making the right choices the access to
those options sure dear Meza Atris
environments environmentalists and the
UN Goodwill Ambassador really appreciate
you talking to us this afternoon thank
you very much it's a pleasure thank you
and thank you for doing what you're
doing the deep ocean life series will
broadcast live news bulletins 300 metres
underwater join us beneath the sea on
Monday the 18th
choose a 19th and Wednesday the 20th of
March